le président de la commission des lois
sur le rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
il était donc écrit que ma première
intervention devant le parlement serait
au sénat je vois je n'y vois pas un
hasard mais une forme au contraire de
symboles et et en même temps
d'invitation de symbole parce que nous
allons aborder un sujet qui n'est pas
partisan la lutte contre le terrorisme
la défense des libertés
l'efficacité de nos dispositifs pénale
notre capacité d'anticipation et de
prévention ce n'est pas une question
partisane c'est une question d'unité
nationale et pour moi l'unité nationale
ce n'est pas autre chose qu'une exigence
dont le fait que ce soit amené à
intervenir comme garde des sceaux
d'abord devant le sénat j'y vois comme
une forme évidemment de plaisir
d'honneur puisque j'ai souvent fréquenté
vos murs dans des réunions commission
mixte paritaire avec s'il bat avec jean
pierre sueur et je n'avais pas eu
l'honneur le privilège de pouvoir
m'adresser à vous donc j'y vois comme
une forme de symbole mais j'y vois aussi
comme une forme d'invitation
l'invitation au dialogue
l'invitation à la recherche
si ce n'est de consensus au moins de
compromis en tout cas l'invitation
permanente à la disponibilité à
l'ouverture à la capacité de construire
ensemble des mesures dans chacun d'entre
nous aura longuement réfléchi en
mesurant l'efficacité et en recherchant
l'utilité jeu